[Musique]
entendre le bruit du moteur prendre soin
de sa voiture jusqu'à la faire importer
certains exposants sont épris de leurs
véhicules de collection c'est un
véhicule qui vient des états unis de los
angeles qui est de 96 g les rapatrier
directement via par l'allemagne et donc
ensuite je les restaurer c'est un
véhicule qui restait 12 ans dans le
département de la police une passion
dévorante pour les voitures à l'image de
lisier son mari propriétaire d'une
chevrolet coupé elle est vraiment dans
son jus on n'a pas touché à la peinture
ni à ses flammes tout tout est d'origine
une passion qui s'étend également pour
son univers de passion c'est tout ce qui
est années 50-60 de rockabilly le
rock'n'roll
voilà tous les chanteurs de ces
années-là quoi c'est notre passion de
maison allait aller dans la collection
aussi avec donc c'est vraiment dans
notre corps quoi c'est notre passion
dans notre dans nouvelle les chineurs de
pièces automobiles étaient au rendez
vous pour cette bourse d'échangés
organisée par l'association le
rendez-vous de la reine on a une
cinquantaine d'exposants voilà et les
gens viennent pour vendre des pièces
exposées aussi des voitures anciennes
notre club date de 2008 on arrive
toujours des fois trouvé des choses
qu'on trouve pas ailleurs des
enjoliveurs des rétros petit support
d'interoute
des petites choses comme ça quoi voilà
sept pas neuve mais bon qui en bon état
ce qui est intéressant c'est d'échanger
avec les propriétaires et puis de
trouver la petite merveille qu'on va
pouvoir ajouter à votre collection
amateurs de véhicules anciens si vous
désirez agrandir votre collection rendez
vous l'an prochain